i appreciate
patrick and
and uh
tyron for what they did and and standing
up
and making a statement
um that allows all of us to to be in a
better place where we can
where love is first and
and uh
and we can we can surround all of
ourselves with great people and most of
all respect the people uh that we come
in contact with
i don't know they to work on that uh
computer placement with andy reid i
expected him to say i am the great and
powerful wizard of oz with flashpots on
each side but uh uh yeah just push the
push the the top of the computer back a
little bit there and it just thought
just a little bit but andy reid's
sentiment is strong and every member of
the chief's organization all the way up
to ownership every fan should be proud
of what patrick mahomes and tyron
matthew have done in this moment this
moment that reveals so much about who
people are and what they are willing to
do and what they are willing to risk and
patron homes hasn't hesitated to use his
platform hasn't hesitated to take a
stand isn't thinking that oh i'm going
to alienate people who may be buying the
products these sponsors are paying me to
endorse no he's doing what's right he
didn't hesitate to get involved in the
video last week and he explained also
shireen mahomes himself that he intends
to continue to use his platform here's
some of what mahomes said yesterday
i think the biggest thing that i i've
done is just lean on people that i
respected i believe done it the right
way and i've been lucky enough uh to
grow up with a lot of great role models
around me and uh just trying to find and
listen to them as they as they talk to
me and then other people around the
league so i feel like i've done it the
right way and listen to the advice they
give me and then trying to make the best
informed decision uh as far as uh what i
do and the next steps i take to move
forward because like you said i've been
given this platform and i want to make
sure i can do whatever i can to make
make the world a better place in
whichever way that is i think it came
from from talking and listening to
teammates and people just throughout our
organization and obviously with the with
the voting coming up as far as local
offices and and and everything like that
we wanted to make sure that was on the
front of our mind we've talked about
several things uh nothing that is
completely informing stone but voter
registration was one big one that we we
really want to move forward with and so
we've had initial talks with clark um
and we've talked with mark donovan and
and we actually we've set up a meeting
for next week with uh our committee uh
and with a lot of the players that are
kind of leaders on our team and we're
gonna try to find the best way to to get
give money or support or whatever it is
to get as many people registered um to
vote and so they can go in and try to
affect change in every way that they
feel possible
using the voice and saying things that
can inspire people to go out and do
things it's doing things as well turning
the words into action spearheading
efforts to get people registered to vote
tyron matthew recently said he wants to
make voting cool uh and and and this is
this is part of of what this moment is
creating an awakening and a realization
that there are specific things that that
can be done to make things better and
and uh yeah it's look the guys the 2018
nfl mvp the 2019 super bowl mvp he's the
favorite to be the 2020 mvp all due
respect to tom brady and any other
player in the nfl patrick holmes is the
nfl right now for him to come out and
and be at the forefront of this is very
very impressive
yeah that was going to be my point mike
in 2018 he did win the mvp award 2019
super bowl mvp and like you said he's
favored
next year but to me this moment that
press conference made him the face of
the nfl forget tom brady forget drew
brees forget whoever it was before
to me now it's patrick mahomes he stood
up in this moment and it was his and he
grabbed it and now he is the face of the
nfl and and he does have this platform
and he plans to use it and use it in a
positive way and i think that's terrific
for what he's done and he's done a lot
of for the community of of kansas city
and yeah this is a kid who grew up with
a dad as a professional athlete his dad
played baseball was a very good
baseball player patrick mahomes is a
great football player and looks like
he's going to have a great hall of fame
type career if if he continues what he's
what he's started he's definitely going
to be in the hall of fame but you know
he's got to continue that but he he is
the face now of the nfl and and uh what
what patrick mahomes says goes and his
part in that video made that video and
his part speaking up now is going to do
really good things for the nfl
and you know playing things forward a
few moves in a few months if there are
protests during the anthem and there are
chiefs players who engage in the protest
and there is a local backlash to it
mahomes is the one who can come out and
say in a very calm measured voice if any
of you have an issue with conscientious
protests during the anthem and you are
among the many who shout chiefs to
replace the last word of the anthem
look in the mirror before you come after
us at least we are doing it for a reason
a real reason not as some sort of a
rallying cry that infringes upon the
national anthem
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports